この度はの半島自身により被災された皆様
並びにそのご家族の皆様に心よりお見舞い
申し上げます被災地の一刻も早い復興をお
祈り申し上げますこの動画の収益の一部を
募金させていただきます少しでも早く子供
たちが笑顔と希望いっぱいで生活できる
世界になりますように今後も動画活動を
続けていき
ますバンキ
ラジオよしダブルスから行けやった行け
行け行け
行け
よしよっしゃうちの子頭はいいんだけど
屋根ちゃんいい加減片付けてくれない
かしら後でするから分かったわ信じるわよ
スカゲムマシン完成やれとやれを合わせる
とマッチョやにダブルマッチや
完成2人を合体させ
たらこれでは完璧
だああいい加減
片付けろにしああもう今からやろうと思っ
たにお母さんがいいからやけなくなった
お母さんのせいだまたやそうこの子は絶対
に片付けをしない子なん
です屋根ちゃんがこのまま育ったら片付け
ができない子になってしまうわまずは作戦
優しくお願い
よやちゃん入るわよおい勝手に入んなよ
やねちゃん昨日はごめんね片付けして
ほしいないや明日も使うし今からけたら
効率が悪くないそっか確かにねちゃんと
考えてて偉いわねお母さんは力が強いだけ
の馬鹿だからしょうがないよこれから
ちゃんと学んでいこうねそうねひちゃん
色々教えて
ね片
しろうなっ
たら片付けだ
わやちゃん楽しく片付けしてみましょうは
音楽祈りなら片付けしたら絶対楽しいから
それではミュージックスツせーのなななな
片付けましょうイイ片付け片付け楽しい
楽しいなななな片付けましょうイエイけ
片付け楽しい楽しななな片付けましょう
イエイ片付け片付け楽しい楽しい
ばばば片付けろよ働け働けばばバババよば
よ楽しくてもダメなら作戦ご褒美だ
わやねちゃん何お片付けしたらご褒美に
100円
あげるなるほどね
やるいいた食べなん
ないおいちび今日俺がパンのもらってきた
ぞやった
ちゃいただき
ます食べなきなんないゆいるはい呼んだ
おと20円やるから俺の家片付けてえ
20円もくれんのありがとうお兄ちゃん
稼いでくれお兄ちゃん頑張っ
てよいしょよいしょよいしょよいしょ
ヘイヘイヘイ片付け終わりましたはい
20円よっしゃこれで新品のキャベ太郎が
買えるん
よお母さんじゃあ100円ちょだい綺麗に
なったわねはいこれ100円よしこれで
今後なりましも毎日8円の収益があるから
1年で100件でスチが変る頭がいいのね
お母さんよこは
ね自分でそう
[音楽]
なさいコミカのお片付け
セミナーこれだ
わどうもコミカ
ですあんな片付けっていうのは物に対する
執着から来てるね執着を手放すと片付けが
はる片付けがはると執着がなくなるこれ
ぐるぐる回ってるねんなこれが執着の観覧
者なぜ片付けが大事なのかっていうのを
子供に教えてあげることが大事やねんな
子供が歩くラウを作ってあげると子供は
そこ教よこれ世界平和やな暴力なんか絶対
あかんで子供は反抗するからな
どうもキカです片付けが進むと執着が
どんどんなくなるねんな執着がなくなると
片付けもどんどんどんどん測とるねんな
これ執着の観覧者やねんやねちゃんわかっ
たいちいち説垂れてきてうるさいんだよ
おばさん
え
え大体さお母さんが俺に片付きが欲しい
から色々やってくる逆に覚めるんだよね
やめてくんない天才はADHDが多いから
さADHDって片付けはできないからんだ
ね親なんだから自分がけだよいちいち子供
に頼るとすんだよ自立しろ
いしせーのせいてててててあのおばさん
絶対許さねえやす大丈夫あみんな明日学校
わりに俺の家遊びに来ない行く行く
行く学校行ってらっしゃいお母さんお願い
があって今日学校間に家に友達呼んでも
いいかないいけどお母さん6時に帰るから
それまでに絶対に片付けしてちょうだいね
もちろんねお母さん大好き行ってき
[音楽]
ます全くあのこったら結局しつけて分から
せるのが1番ね
うわー
[拍手]
[音楽]
りよこれでだいぶ汚れたなみんなそろそろ
時間だからまたねじゃまた明日じゃ
[拍手]
ね
ただいま何これ
あのガキめちゃくちゃにちやがって
バーななんだのよ
これお母さん俺はもう怒ったよ絶対に
片付けないから自分でつけ
なされ
ぞあのガキ絶対許さない
[音楽]
わ俺こっちでってこいあいつこのサッカー
ボール
[音楽]
もこの野郎
何なのよこれ絶対トイレ
ねえ何これ
何これ気持ちが悪い
わそしたらこっち
ね
えなんであんたたちいんの
住んでる
[音楽]
のいつからいた
のごめんこれは俺も分からないやあたいた
の
[音楽]
ね
こちこち
こち待なさい
ここね
えあここサウナ室なんであああここ開いて
ますよあ
じゃあどう
も
週7ああそすよね中でいいしいやあ暑い
ですね冬って現状大変でサウナとかゆく
行くんです
[音楽]
よ屋根ちゃんし走に来たじゃないの何し
てんのよはここっちだってこっちす待ち
なさい待ち
なさい
なもう追い詰めたわよやね
ちゃんさよなら
お母さんはなん
だえ
え
球の裏側るじゃない
の
片付けこの2つのゴミを合わせたらゴミ
人間の完成だ
ゴミさダブルキーコ
だお母さんは片付に執着してるからその悩
を消すためにこのを片付けてあげて
よてててててて
えなんであんたたちもいいの
よ
さあここは排除されたものの世界これで
悩みもなくなったね
お母さんどうなってん
の
よしこれで片付けをしたくなくなる夢を見
てるあら俺のキチだ
あ実
はお母さんが爆弾に引っかかった
時ナイトメアマシンで夢を見せてたんだ
そうこれまでのは全部夢なん
[音楽]
だ私があんたを片付けるかあんたが今から
この家を片付けるかどっちか選び
なさいちょちょうど今片付けようと思って
たところなんだよねお母さんちょっと
せかしすぎだって今からやろうと思ったん
だから
出
はいれれれ
あちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最はチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録